hey everybody and welcome to a wild ride
that'll pull on your heartstrings
because we get personal
we get vulnerable and we pour
jackass all over it yeah dude
ladies and gentlemen danger aaron
yeah dude hi everybody
hi hi scott welcome yep i don't have to
introduce you to scott have you met my
gorgeous other co-hosts
yes we met uh several years ago i
believe yeah was it
it might have been and then you met on
facebook once covet hit dude time has
been warped so bad like i swear to god
we met over a uh a computer zoom call to
talk about his tooth
that's right when we did the tooth video
yeah oh that's right
okay and that was i think the only time
that was not long ago how long did you
say two years ago that was like a week
ago or something
i mean a week no is like
maybe four months the first time i met
you was when you guys did the uh
the waxing mustache oh yeah i thought we
met before that i don't think so that
was because i was when you went to
portland
okay so that was that was like 14 years
ago 2014.
did the world 2014 that's what i mean
yeah would you say it's not a the waxing
mustache
it was uh that was a [ __ ] classic bit
dude that was like
early on the youtube deal yeah you guys
came up that's when you're growing out
your stash to do different
looks for acting no i don't think it had
anything to do with acting i
i for all i know i was growing it out to
wax it
i don't know sounds about right so long
ago i don't remember
you had almost you had a beard a beard
maybe
but let's uh make this [ __ ] kick ass
like right out of the gate um have you
announced
to the world what what you have to
announce
oh i have lots to announce what you're
referring to
what what what'd you say you're having a
baby
i didn't see [ __ ] oh i'm just kidding
it is
the world and i was joking like are you
pregnant yeah so yeah no i thought you
knew and then you were just saying that
and then you felt bad because you said
it
because a lot of times if somebody told
somebody and they weren't supposed to
tell that person that they got told
that's the big one it's like oh i wasn't
i'm sorry i'm right like
full disclosure full disclosure i said
it
and i was joking and i forgot but we
spoke on the phone a couple days ago and
you told me when we were when we were
talking about the merch operations
yes but when it came out of my mouth i
was like oh [ __ ] up
i'm doing anything i'm supposed to tell
anybody i'm just trying to be funny and
say oh you're pregnant like you know
i'm sorry dude no it's funny i don't
have i've been having a moment
yeah way to blow it for me dude there's
like
so many cameras in here it's not just
audio
taking my glory bro dude but
it's it's the first trimester
is you only tell people who are like
super who are like
you're you're you'll be comfortable
saying you got a miscarriage yeah but
how many times have you been pregnant
never okay so i can tell you from my
experience
it's i've never been had had a child
before or
anything uh i've i've raised a child i
love
my step child lucia but i've never
actually
gone through the process of of birth
like this and
it's it's a it's it's cr on itself it's
amazing
and wild and crazy but during covid
it's like i don't know i would i don't
even know what to compare it to but
for people that have talked to me about
like having a child during covet they've
all been like it's just crazy i can't go
to any of the meetings or you know i
can't go with this and that and
i don't know who to tell because i'm
normally you have like a baby shower or
you have some event where you can get
everyone together so then the event
becomes a zoom call or some instagram
post
how far are steepos
not only did nobody know like during the
first trimester
his child is expected to be born on may
21st
yeah and if you think about it literally
like a couple months
like yeah they're way down the track but
i was filming jackass
four and at the time i was doing
something or very
you know let's just say dangerous to a
certain part of my body
multiple times over and over again and
you know
maybe he thought that if
everybody knew that he was expecting a
child that they would be like oh well
he's already reproduced like
you know we can like go extra super hard
on him yeah but
come to find out i couldn't go any
harder than we already did
like so yeah of course we can't we can't
say anything but like
let's just say that they're gonna have
to
not show like what actually
happened in a lot of cases because to
show what happened would just be too
much they'd
you know just way
i went to i was so crazy on this
new movie yeah like are you but i broke
my neck so many times
i told jeff and and knox i'm like listen
i can't break my neck again so i'm gonna
have to figure out something else to do
well we figured it out so they broke the
opposite part of your body no it's
functioning bro that's
enough enough said um about all that but
yeah dude so danger's gonna be a dad
and and uh congrats congratulations
thank you girl
girl oh i wanna say two would you would
you think about
about my covent joke when uh oh last
night i went to your show and the
the one about not having children well
it was just it was just
it was about the pandemic i said how
like man thousands of people dying every
day
oh yeah it sounds serious but i don't
have any context so i just i i was too
curious i had to find out how many
people die anyway
and turns out before the pandemic uh the
average
deaths in america every day was 7500
but that's not what's shocking what's
shocking is how many
average births there's eleven thousand
americans born
everywhere is that just americans or
women in america in america just in
america
so i'm like okay so once i've given that
statistic
11 000 are born every day eleven
thousand
and one
[Laughter]
so we're next four thousand a day yeah
okay
so then the punch line is which begs the
question
should the coronavirus not pick up the
pace
we might be in trouble right i mean it's
getting kind of crowded around here
i mean it is i'm looking at traffic
right now yeah it's not just here
and around here it's everywhere the
population of the earth is
sure it's too many it's double what it
should be and it's going to continue to
rise and
we're like we're like ants in a molehill
or an ants in an ant farm anthill and
all that just like they're everywhere
ants are really strong and smart
geniuses
except for when they take the bait every
time that's like come on
little bro just brought back all that
stuff i'm gonna kill you all with
so she killed you last time what are you
doing so when we've done
stand up like uh together there was
there was a period where
like a spokane we were doing all
like uh you know everybody from jackass
except for
like like bam in knoxville and we met
like all of us were doing shows together
and whenever i go up to uh portland
oregon
yeah uh or seattle like i will do shows
together
and and you talk a lot about how you
grew up in a funeral home
and uh like you've got the joke about
about
what was it that you would like crawl
into the
coffins and pretend to be dead oh man so
i i mean i was a kid you know seven
years old but i grew up in a mortuary
since the age of three so
what's the difference between a mortuary
and a funeral home same
okay if you know home and more toy um
and your dad is a funeral director yes a
mortician
that's what my cousin is yeah so he does
make up the services everything
um grieving with the family and
it's gnarly man it's crazy but so i
don't know like
one day i was in the casket room where
he sells caskets
and the family who was crying and i i
got in there into the cast room right
before they did
and i closed down this casket and i laid
in it
and as the my dad lifted the casket to
show them
the inside of it to sell it to them for
the one you know they just lost their
loved one
i jumped out of it went crazy and i
got out and he looked at me and just
said get upstairs and you know when your
dad talks really quietly
back in the 80s yeah
by his belt that had his initials on it
or his whole
letter or his whole name on it because
back then everyone i don't know it was
cool to make your own leather belt and
stamp your name into it
so he worked my ass doesn't
i was alive for like three months of the
80s i i don't understand this new
like way of life like just posting
everything you do
and not doing anything for real i don't
know it's
how do you how do you keep busy during
the day oh wait sorry were you going
somewhere
i was just curious like is the funeral
home still
like what your dad does like no he's
retired now um
so there's not gonna be your kid is not
gonna grow up in a funeral home
no that won't happen why you make it
sound like it wasn't a real treat to
girls it was a real treat
that's a real treat man you're weird
[ __ ] creep
yeah what does that do to somebody well
basically
like so at a very young age i realized
i had this epithelia so i came in i
remember
the lady what kind of an epiphany did
you have as a young buck
at the age of you know actually it was i
was about nine i think
and epiphany amber thiessen
that was so good i'm sorry dude no but
she
she stopped me and i just had come home
with books in my hand and from
elementary school and she stopped me and
thought i was part of the family
and she's telling me about her the
husband that she had lost she was an
older lady elderly
and she was telling me all these stories
and everything and and then i basically
just kind of walked off went upstairs to
my room
but it made me realize that the stories
and the memories that
you share and the people you connect
with in this planet that we call earth
is that is what life is and if you can
let go of
life and be positive and not look back
and say i burned people i did bad stuff
and whatever
then you can just let let go and that's
heaven and leaving behind
memories of stories with with family and
loved ones and
being a good person so it meant a lot to
me and so
i i wanted to basically do that for
forever but it made me realize that i
wanted to
do something to the masses like
entertain
be an entertainer or something an
athlete like do something where
i could like make a big splash not just
for my little town
that's just me personally and then
that's kind of however became danger
aaron
you know snowboarding pro snowboarder
trying to just
so so you got your way into jackass was
very much
the same as dave england you guys were
like uh like a package deal
um well i was snowboarding up in oregon
dave had moved up there i'm
from oregon um and uh
david said dave england got in and he
was like yo
no it was actually whitey my friend
whitey oh yeah whitey okay
told those guys because we were filming
stuff up there just funny
whatever gags snowboarding stuff and i
had written a couple ideas
and so they flew up there to film the
pilot
with dave and myself because the idea
that i
had turned in they were just like oh
what that's crazy okay let's do it but
what was that idea like urban kayaking
oh there was so many urban kayaking
blind driver
um all the danger aaron like extreme
scooting like that whole character
didn't you know danger what was the
gnarliest the pogo stick this this shirt
i love that dude i love when he pogo
sticks onto the skateboard it's one of
my favorite
this is actually a shirt i had made um
by mikey boss dog and he he did this
graphic for me i said i
all i want is a pogo stick i want my
orange jumpsuit
and my pogo stick from the first skit i
ever filmed and that was that was the
first game
that was um i showed up just to god that
was such a genius
[Laughter]
too i know it's doable i couldn't quite
figure it out
but i mean how many tries did you take
on the the
that you mean just the the pogo i would
imagine that you would have trouble
committing to that
no no trouble committing i full
committed back in the day and i still do
you know you've seen it
and this was you you did a pogo stick
right on to escape yeah i was trying to
basically become the first pogo skater
yeah and that's why i made this shirt
and and so
it's pretty good that's great man i
became the first stilts skateboarder
there you go and uh wow did that [ __ ] me
up
i don't think i ever saw that anymore i
didn't do i did it on stage
at spring break i don't even know if
there was [ __ ] footage rolling
and i landed just straight on my ribs
and like
i i didn't even break a rib i just like
bruised them right there because that's
even worse couldn't laugh you're
laughing hurt so bad like and
sneezing oh my god yeah the worst and
when was the first time that you guys
met
well so back to this pogo thing um i
showed up
on for the pilot this was like way
before we even had a tv show
so it wasn't even called jackass at that
point no no it wasn't it wasn't called
jackass it was just a
show that we were trying to sell to
either mtv
or comedy central it hadn't been bought
yet so we were just doing them
you know you had yours was it on that
trip when dave england had the
the fake baby on the bicycle and crashed
the bicycle
um that was the following
trip i think they came up where they
actually came up for
about a week to film that first pilot we
did
was two weeks two days it was a weekend
shoot we came up
and i showed up dressed as danger aaron
for no reason whatsoever i just showed
up in that
the danger iron outfit with that you
care about leaving people a legacy of
entertainment yes
and i figured what better way to just
hug myself off of things
was that sorry was that like the
character
you know danger aaron was it invented
for that or it was no no
it actually came from um uh two years
prior i
dressed up as a race car driver and we
bought an ltd and we
we went backwards all through portland
and
uh and then the next year i didn't have
an outfit for halloween so i went as
danger aaron which was the race car
driver outfit and all of my injuries
were
which at the time at the age of 20 i
believe it was
a neck brace an arm brace a leg brace a
leg
all your medical paraphernalia yeah yeah
and a crutch
and and then i went for halloween as
danger aaron and then
later that you know next year whatever
when they showed up i still had that
costume and so i showed up with my
helmet and my
mechanic suit that you know has my name
or whatever
and then dave was pogo sticking and i
just got out of the car and i was like
hey can i try
and i and then i just went through all
through portland pogo sticking
bad it's a cute story but the reality is
that the name
aaron mcgee sucks
that's the real truth yeah but stephen
glover's much better
you're the first gilchrist i've ever
heard yeah you know what knoxville's
real name is
yeah we do yeah you'd love to say it on
phillip
john clapp what's this what's your piece
he's named after an std
but wait is clap spelled c-l-a-p-p it is
why i
don't know how the std no i know his
name
how much hardware do you have in your
body by hardware scott means
plates and screws that one gets
surgically drilled into their bones
when they've been broken beyond what the
body can repair
naturally so i love my hardware
and i love the hardware that i wear
outside my body on my right wrist
because it makes life like a video game
see it's called a woop band
and it is the most epic fitness tracking
device
out there it gives me so much insight
into my activities how many calories i
burn
how much rest i'm getting what kinds of
rest that like
it just motivates me to stay more active
to get better score on my rest to just
be a healthier person
it makes my life better and i want you
to try it
get yourself a woop band the woop band
is completely free
and what you do is you go on woop.com
that's w-h-o-o-p
com to sign up for your membership and
when you do that
if you use the promo code stevo you get
15 off at checkout
so do that head to woop.com use the
promo code stevo
get 15 off at checkout and let your life
be a really fun video game that makes
you healthier
now let's talk about dangerous hardware
um i have had three broken necks
so i've got a fusion at c5 and six
a disc replaced at six and seven a disc
replaced at seven
t1 and then my neck fused itself at c2
and three because of
scarring from like injuries um and how
many of those
injuries you just listed are from
jackass uh i broke my neck twice
in the last film we did previous to what
we are just working on now so what's
what bits uh i think it was number three
there was uh
up in the snow shopping cart he was
sitting there and they were gonna have
him ski across like
some little body of water yeah no but i
got in a shopping cart
and i've been the fastest built on water
skis or something it was uh no it was on
regular skis and and eric
rohner all right right pushed me through
uh down the hill and they built this
pond that i was supposed to land in
and the gag was that i'd get wet and
then i'd walk over to get a towel and
they would just
a hole like an eight-foot hole drop
drops off and then i eat [ __ ] in there
and then i
think some mistakes or some [ __ ] well no
and i told jeff i was like yo
i'm pretty good with knowing how like
velocity and like
stuff i've made a career off of this my
whole life has been about
hucking my body and surviving and i said
i'm gonna hit that wall
i'm gonna flip hit that wall and break
my neck and he's like no you'll be fine
and sure enough i did and it whips
and i knocked out and i get in the water
and i'm
i'm i'm fully concussed and i come too
because it's ice cold water and i get up
and i'm like oh my god and everyone's
looking at me literally like they
thought they killed me
in full speed and regular speed it was
[ __ ] violent as [ __ ]
yeah and and i'm standing there like
looking at them like
like should i be walking right now like
what should i do because i feel like i'm
i'm dying and they all looked at me like
oh god what that went wrong
what do we do now and then somebody said
the towels are over there and i'm not
[Applause]
even knowing that i had already probably
like
i was a [ __ ] ghost i was just walking
they they thought they killed me
they didn't understand it fell in the
hole and i'm laying in there go
are you kidding me right now
just like that
no because they felt so bad that's
another example where they couldn't show
what actually happened
because it was too much if we had just
like not the 0.5 because even the 0.5
can't show the
like a lot of the gnarly stuff if we had
i mean i don't know that there's that
much
footage that was like couldn't be shown
i mean
it sounds like like uh you're falling
with a broken neck into an eight-foot
hit like it does count why but like
there's
lots of things man we've been doing this
for 21 years
like why would he what comes to mind
yeah well okay take for instance i did
something that you would have seen that
you might not know the backstory of what
you really could have seen
um yellow snow cone where i
i pee into a snow cone i saw that and i
was like man that's low
brow even for us no but not at the
beginning and it was
it was awesome like you can say what you
want
people remember it that's true
absolutely
yeah so so my original idea with that
was that i wanted to make a snoopy snow
cone machine
like p cone and we couldn't get like
hasbro or
whoever owns that brand to clear off
that so
so i was like okay well what about this
and we just stuffed
you know date with snowing in portland
in dave's backyard
and that's when we filmed that and i
peed in a snow cone
and i ate it and it was pretty narrow
but it wasn't like
super gnarly like compared to what yeah
we do now but back then it was like
you don't show that stuff for real on a
movie tv or was it on that
that was the movie it was in the first
movie like you just don't show real
stuff like that on a
film in a theater theaters at the time
and so i did that they've kicked me the
nuts
that felt really not cool whatever
and i dropped to my knees and i started
puking because it was disgusting and he
hit me
kicked me so hard on the dick that my
stomach basically like was exploding
with all the food that i had just eaten
and so i puked all over the place and
then i stuff i pick up that
snow and i stuff it into the snow cone
thing and i
look at the camera dimitri i think and i
go and now this
is the brown snow cone and then i ate my
puke
in the snow and they never showed that
they can't show that it's not because
it's disgusting i don't know i mean
you can't show that like we did that but
there was they ever showed the vomit
when uh dave they we had to reshoot that
three times just to get it because of
all the
and that was why they had hazmat suits
and [ __ ] i'm not sure i talked to jeff
the other day about that i don't know
like i can't remember how about on the
first movie when you did the mousetrap
thing and you were like crawling around
in the with all the mousetraps
everywhere yeah and that was like it was
like all right that's kind of cute but
then what was like the most
amazing thing that anybody had ever seen
was when
was it knoxville through the mouse trap
yeah like how [ __ ] incredible was
that can you imagine trying to do that
on purpose
you know it'll never happen again yeah
the thing about doing the mousetraps
that was so gnarly or
whatever impressive to me was that when
you set 2 000 mouse traps if one goes
off
a lot of them go off and then you've got
the that whole problem and we
like were able to set 2 000 mouse traps
for me to roll through so that was
pretty cool
what would you say if they were like
okay we're going to redo that old
mousetrap bit but it's going to be rat
traps with rat traps yeah i
i i'm uh why what's the difference
bigger and harder
yeah they're heavy dude rat traps if a
rat trap gets
clamped around your balls you you're not
having balls dude
so just don't just squish them
completely so when you put your tongue
on a trap it's a mouse trap yeah you
don't do a rat trap oh
you could yeah rat traps are [ __ ] up
what's the point
right yes it may be a little too much i
don't know i get it maybe
so let me let me ask you about this
because this is something that i feel
like pretty strongly about like
over the years like all 21 of them
like you've kind of like been uh
like sort of a whipping boy you know
it's yeah it's like
everyone just be mean to danger aaron
like where what makes jackass so special
is this like camaraderie this charisma
or could not charisma this chemistry
that we have between
us yet like
it's just like bullying you've been yeah
you've been the victim of very much
bullying for sure for like you know a
lot of the time
dude and and it's hard for me sometimes
because
well a lot of times for any purpose of
somebody being
bullied but i'm you know in a sense
being uh outcasted and bullied
and it's all in good fun is so everyone
says but the reality is is no matter
what eventually you just get
tired of the same repetitive jokes that
are being
put towards you right and
that's it's different because it's my
job i'm not like this
in person like if you [ __ ] with me like
i'm sorry you
like i'm not gonna just take it like i
do with while we're filming
stuff because right it's we need that
person like
as a group we really do like if we
didn't have me
i guess but
what happens in this situation a lot of
times is like
one person will say something and in
order for them not to get picked on
they make sure that they're dishing out
and then all of a sudden everyone else
will just kind of follow suit right
behind it's a normal thing in life
people do it right same way in order for
them not to feel like oh they're coming
after me
let's go after that person and then my
the attention will not be on me
anymore or or you know what i'm saying
and
yeah it's almost like maybe maybe
they're getting bullied at home but
they're not kids
all i know uh is who i am
you know as as you getting hot
yeah can we open up that
that window sorry dude you can max air
that stuff and the little blaster fan
mm-hmm this thing's set up for all
terrain
do you does it ever come also like
all-terrain interviews cause people
people who watch jackass they feel so
close to you guys they feel like they're
your buddies
so do people come up to you and feel
like they can bully you because no
no i think most people come up to me and
they can relate to
what happened that's cool because no
matter like
yeah there's like you know there's the
cool guy and the cool guy like everyone
thinks that's cool that cool guy's
getting picked on
all the time too like even if it's just
people don't
respect that person or something like we
we're all human beings
like we have like we need to take care
of each other
what does morrissey say like i'm just a
human and
and i i need to be loved yeah
there you go i can't remember what we
were just talking about though you said
that
um i said everybody bullies you
yeah and i mean a lot of times it's
funny i mean
like yeah i mean a lot of it's funny and
i do agree with you that maybe like to
an extent we need that
but i said when i brought this up
initially i feel strongly about it
because i think that
you know for a lot of the time it's just
gone too far
it's totally it's gone past the point of
being like playful and fun and it's like
what's the point it gets to the point
where it's like what's the point
of saying mean things to a person when
uh there's not even cameras being rolled
and a lot of times like not a lot of
times but sometimes and it's not just to
me it's to everybody like
we latch on to somebody else to
take the blame off of us and that's what
happens with this we get nine guys 10
guys together whatever
now it's like a morning everybody gets
[ __ ] there's no question about that but
it just goes
with you it's just it's been too much a
lot of the time and it's been when
cameras aren't rolling and it's like
yeah
and and i've just you know i i
i'm speaking up for you man because i i
love you and you're a great guy
hey you don't deserve that [ __ ] thank
you yeah thank you
well here's what here's what you just
said is i'm a great guy
i mean i don't know if i'm a great guy
but i'm a good person i'm a good guy
and at the end of the day and at the end
of the day
whatever people say or do to me like i
go home i'm like dude i'm killing it in
life
like i'm killing it in life i've got the
best life
i'm the same person i was before i
started
jackass like i'm i'm
i feel like you can't say [ __ ] to me
like literally
you can't say [ __ ] to me that's gonna
like make me not
really know who i am and and respect
myself i agree with you
think i have to be really strong to be
able to still continue to hear that [ __ ]
over and over again because
i'm not letting it it does affect me and
eventually
i get over it and i'm just like fine
then you guys can
talk [ __ ] to yourselves i'm going to
walk over here go back to one of your
nine
houses go back to one of my nine houses
and chill dog
but you have to be strong like your
shirt says
you do in in life especially when people
are like
giving [ __ ] for no reason all you want
to do is crawl up into a ball and be
like [ __ ] they're right i
suck but you don't you know i don't suck
i don't care
well just look at the people tell me
what you want you know it's like even
like the comments on some of the videos
it's like dude
who's actually saying that and why would
you say that to anybody do
comments on social media it's like the
way that
the world works right now with social
media and how easy it is to just
ridicule people and make them feel like
[ __ ] for no reason it's ridiculous
that's turned into normal society
now and that's not how we need to live
like what's the point in telling
everybody what they're doing wrong
instead of like saying hey you're doing
this right and you could fix this or do
that better
but you're not always just doing wrong
like like that's not going to benefit us
all
it's a spiritual axiom meaning like
an immutable law of nature that
the way we treat others is a reflection
of how we feel about ourselves and
that's why it's all the hating and
negativity you know it's like
you got some [ __ ] [ __ ] going on with
yourself and you don't like it and so
you take it out on other people
like in general like happy healthy
people don't [ __ ] on others
yeah you know well you but but it's
different with this because
we this is this is i mean honestly i am
i'm 100 percent sure that
we all love each other like yeah like
like yeah
like we're family and you have a brother
or sister and and you love that person
and you still pick on that person and
it's not it doesn't excuse it but
usually
what happens when you get older in life
like in your 40s and 50s is you're like
mature enough to then say you know i'm
sorry i i don't mean to pick
i didn't mean to pick on you yeah but we
aren't
mature we are jackass like we aren't
supposed to grow up we're supposed to be
like doing this as i guess forever but
so
that normal like growing up phase and
and being like hey man
i just want to let you know i love you
and like i tell you i'm sorry
yeah i know i tell that to you too yeah
dude so do you think maybe the other
guys feel like
since you're you sort of said like you
know you almost played this role of
being like that out of a joke
but it's almost their job also to like
throw it at you and kind of like give
you this [ __ ] and like they're like
this is just work for me like yeah
maybe you might have a little bearing
and you know it's like it's just
it's accepted it's it's what as we've
done for so long
yeah but you know i i don't i
i would like to think that if i were on
the other side of it
like i wouldn't be like rousting
the dude over and over again and because
i can see when i do it
to some of our new crew or whatever i
can see their
their emotions and their their whole
like outlook on like their spirit like
like when i when when i see other people
start doing things to them i see them
instantly just like go into this
like oh man i i i'm like oh no like
and it totally makes it it'll be hard
enough coming in like to a new crew and
then you get
rousted it's like jesus maybe i don't
belong here well there's
but you should you should get [ __ ]
with
you know but there's a certain point at
which
because i get [ __ ] with i know like
okay
it's about to cross the line i don't
want to like there's no point in me
hurting his or her feelings for anything
right now
we're not even filming what's the point
hey man just know this i'm just trying
to teach you something that's it that's
all
cool and then it's like oh okay cool and
then it's like seniors and freshmen
yeah so what was the conversation
that you and i had we had a conversation
on the flight
of home from india or like yeah was
actually going to india and
i think we sat next to each other on the
way back too i remember
bonding i remember that it's been
something that we reflected on
like many years later but i hadn't
gotten sober
yet i was a [ __ ] pile of pile you
weren't dude it was like
the conversation so we're going to india
what movie was this two number two yeah
we're going to india and they paired
stevo up with me
on the 17-hour flight to india
you guys find the first question
steve you were like this was like this
was like
the beginning of the end this was like
this was the beginning of the the
gnarliest you could ever be in
doing like um drugs like you
this was going to india yeah so you got
a nose full of cocaine
before you got on the flight
but i can tell you this i i do know that
you did smuggle drugs because i smoked
some weed out of your ass
okay good so that came from his butt
good so
yeah i don't know how it got there i
swallowed a condom i probably swallowed
like
five or six condoms full of weeds really
you didn't just do one you did like five
or six
yeah he had weed i got to
on this plane for 17 hours and he's like
just
what i'm like dude um what so what's up
like what what do you come
like what's your story like like let's
we got a lot of time to talk let's talk
about real stuff
let's talk about life outside of this
cool [ __ ] we do
of jackass and we got to talk and i was
like you know man
like none of this really matters like
what matters is you're
you like you matter and you need to take
care of yourself like
everyone likes crazy stevo and we all
love that crazy stevo but if there's no
crazy stevo anymore because crazy steve
will kill himself i'm [ __ ] doing too
many drugs
and you had no responsibility for
anything i said to you i was like
you need to take care of yourself man
and i love you and i care about you
and i truly believe you have the ability
to be a
like a rad person because you were not a
red person yeah
definitely not and and we talked and we
kept talking
and and then we smoked uh weed from your
butthole
later on
[Laughter]
his response was totally like kind of
shocked
i remember you were like shocked that i
would even bring that up or talk about
it
like because it was it was like your
mortal enemy uh
you didn't want to like acknowledge what
you were really doing
and i stopped you and made you
acknowledge it and you were you were
like
you're really concerned you're on my
[ __ ] list for the next day yeah was he
competitive or sort of like receptive
and so
you weren't you were competitive we
bonded it was we had a bro down
yeah and then that was the second but
that was
three uh how many years before you got
you cleaned up on that about two years
before two years that
two years more went by so that was like
the beginning of yeah
really taking off that stuff and then
then we did the mtv special the 24-hour
takeover
before that everybody keeps talking
about this 24-hour takeoff oh
whatever wait i want to talk about the
end of the
the second movie like you had the the
pubic beard
yeah and that idea came about because
we had a a writing session at jeff
tremaine's house
to come up with ideas for the movie yeah
and and i said uh
just in in this meeting i said hey man
for what it's worth
i uh like looked at my my
bush my pubic hair was just like such a
gnarly afro
like uh you had to i shaved it off and
i shaved it off and it was so much
puberty it was such a big
bush like i stepped it into an empty
drug baggie
yeah like uh i've done this several
times
[Music]
it's sitting in my uh in my medicine
cabinet in my bathroom
um and so we're like okay what can we do
with with pubic hair and like it the
whole idea didn't come up in that
session but that was like the genesis
like
where it all came so you end up with
everyone's pubic hair yeah
super glued to your face which by the
way i would do that
i've said this every day i i i would i
i've said and i would really do every
day
for like i would say almost the rest of
my life have to shave off
your dicks pubic hair
off my beard didn't break my neck again
seriously that makes sense so so so i'm
like
every person in the world would agree
with you on that
i got one yeah and it was simple yeah
[ __ ] movie and possibly
all time of jackass and i didn't have to
break my neck i don't know dude
done with the carbs the pubic beard
the big beard was good though because it
was like that part within a prank aspect
where aaron thinks he's pranking this
guy but that prank is all on him like
but
it was perfect but dunn's car up the ass
is probably this is
like the best thing that's pretty much
the best thing yeah but
the reason i bring up the pubic beard
and and what the bit was called it was
called the terror taxi
with the pubic hair on your and then
like the the whole
terrorist bomb thing yeah and uh
you after it was filmed
you told everybody oh i knew it was
pubic hair i was just being a bro
i was just going along with it because i
didn't want to ruin the bit
but i knew okay you want me to tell you
the truth i mean
this is a controversy that's that's
raged on forever since the beginning
since the beginning of the day he's got
an
answer oh i'm i don't lie
i don't need to lie why do i need to lie
about anything my life is so crazy
already
so that whole time you and you
absolutely
so i walked in this is huge so
i walked into train's office and he says
to me we're gonna film
and i don't care at this point i can
tell like anybody everybody and i've
told it
as verbatim the same way every time
because it's the truth
but i don't care to tell the whole world
now it doesn't matter i don't think that
you've told it the same every time
i have i've told it the same every time
that's the way it went down
no i didn't know about the pb okay so
check this out
so i walk in now we got another version
listen i'm going back to the beginning
of how i even ended up in this skit
i'm not at that time i didn't know there
was going to be any
hair involved on my face but i can tell
you this
that tremaine told me that he we were
going to film the skit that i wrote
years ago and i went through all of my
notes when i got home because i write
everything down
and catalog it and i didn't find it
anywhere and i had already turned in
some
[ __ ] gold for this movie and it
wasn't being filmed so
i knew it was a setup i'm like i told my
girlfriend at the time i said
they're either gonna pull a gun out or a
knife out or they're going to take me i
thought what they were going to do
is take me to jail and [ __ ] with me in
jail and
so that was where mine was my mind was
going so
when they're put in the pubic hair the
dick hair as i refer to on my
chin or on my face all over it i even
said is this pubic hair and
and it's in the film i think it was i
think they used that yeah
yeah yeah and and and she goes no it's
hollywood hair and at that point i
didn't even
process or give a [ __ ] because i
realized that what is happening right
now is
hilarious right so i went into the taxi
i didn't know his
channel c car whatsoever i should have
because he's
neighbors but i'm sitting behind him and
dimitri's sitting next to me
and we're filming going to do this
[ __ ] gnarly terrorist taxi bit and so
i'm in character
saying take me through the brittany
geared for please and all those things
and
and i don't know it's jay and dimitri's
looking over at me saying
like saying like hey hey say that one
and i said something
something that he had said to me and
then i started talking about
liking women's breasts and stuff and and
then
i'm like yeah we're going this way and
then all of a sudden we're
in a parking lot and jay gets out and
i'm like
i [ __ ] got a bum and why would i say
i've got a [ __ ] bomb it's totally
fake with the dude who's pointing a gun
at me
like do you think i would actually be i
know i'd be like dude i'm so sorry
instantly
so the only way out for me was to look
like a badass
and act tough and so i was like [ __ ] you
dude
i got a [ __ ] bomb what are you gonna
do and all this [ __ ] so you said you
still thought this was
i'm not real or fake no i haven't you
know you knew it was a bit
at that point you didn't look like you
knew it was a bit exactly
but i'm telling you the truth okay okay
i knew what you're telling me you can't
process
it's truth i mean this i don't know
dig this story like this no no no the
stories go in the same direction the
whole time
i knew it was a setup i didn't know
about the pubic hair i said this is
pubic hair but then i didn't even think
about it anymore because i want to stay
in character
the whole time i'm being abducted all of
a sudden with the
he tells me to get out get on the ground
i'm in the back of the
[ __ ] taxi and i'm literally laughing
my ass off like under my breath because
i know i'm mike
and bam says something and i go that's
ben marcher he's famous
you should listen to him like you think
i'm gonna say that [ __ ] if i'm terrified
of my life
but i remember there's a point where
you're in the van and you're like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
stupid what the [ __ ] you [ __ ]
i'm sick of this [ __ ] get me out of here
that was
fake no it was entertaining
okay so if i understand correctly
you didn't know it was pubic hair glue
it was pubic hair glued all over my face
that it wasn't a real taxi driver
i knew it was a setup i knew as a setup
the minute jeff told me that i wrote the
skit and i went back through all my
notes from all the last many years
and couldn't find it when i knew that we
had already turned in
really great ideas and we're wasting
time doing this what is this old skit i
don't
i didn't write it if i didn't write it
but we're filming it but he told me i'm
writing i wrote it then
it's a setup i don't know how it's going
to go down but i know it's a setup
all right so as soon as the cab driver
pulls the gun
in your head you know this is a bit uh a
prank on me
yeah so but then so you just
sort of play it for the camera like uh
the way you did it i feel bad telling
everybody all the time over and over
because especially they don't believe me
this is one but it's the truth like i'm
like it's not just a once and for all
because this will spark new conversation
of like
why like why would you even say that
it's not true i'm like it is
it's just the truth it's how it went
down i am the one person that knows i
don't understand
what you've explained so let's i didn't
know about
the pubic hair i knew it was somehow a
setup i didn't know how it was going to
go down
my thought was and i told my girlfriend
at the time that it was gonna be like i
got a gun pulled on me
a knife or something like that or taken
to jail
where then i get [ __ ] with like leave
me overnight with cameras everywhere
and i'm freaking out that i didn't know
it was going to stop there
and then when i come out and i'm acting
or i'm scared
whatever right right then they tell me
about the pubic hair and then that
processes through my mind like
oh [ __ ] like that's disgusting now
that i have a moment
to just take a breath and then i started
puking because it was in my mouth
where i had just ripped out a tooth or
something there were crabs in your mouth
yeah and then that that was all that's
all real
like come on man okay good was the dick
hair really that necessary
yeah and i made sweatshirts too that
said right yeah i like it
anyways so so i think that
of all the guys on jackass that that you
are
probably the most like well adjusted
in that you don't really subscribe to
fame or celebrity you don't really
identify as that you're just
a normal guy you live a normal life and
i think you've also been more
entrepreneurial
with the money that you got from jackass
than most any of the other guys
in that you've taken it and invested it
in all this real estate like you said
you own nine houses
like uh you had seven right now right
yeah
and i when i found out about this real
estate initiative that you were all
into and that you had like at the time
like what nine or ten houses
i i remember thinking dude danger that's
great
while the market's doing well but like
dude these how
if the real estate market crashes you
always have a backup plan
what's the backup plan well i bought my
first house
off the first movie where we made just
like you know we didn't make that much
money but i i bought a
building uh down payment in my hometown
where i grew up to start a skate shop
so i bought the building and got a loan
for the business because it's better to
own the real estate than it is to have a
business you can fail a business but if
you own the property
you continue to rent it out and whatever
else and so
that's the mcdonald's movie yeah no this
was way before that movie came out but
it's the way it is
[ __ ] that dude he's a liar
i'm gonna tell you the truth no i'm
kidding so
i i took the money that i made for that
movie and i moved back
i lived in hollywood at the time for
like three years trying you know being a
part of the whole thing whatever it was
great time
but i moved back to my hometown and
started my skate shop and bought a house
and since then i've i've acquired many
homes uh that i've
you know vacation rentals and whatever
else being involved in real estate
is a long-term game it's not something
you do there's a lot of people that flip
homes
and if you have decent credit you can
get in the game of that
and that's a pretty good living but my
plan was because i'm fourth generation
oregonian i love oregon
i wanted to own as much in oregon that
places that i would want to live and
that's my philosophy behind it and
basically
uh in the long game of it is there's
like
a up and down it's a roller coaster the
real estate market it's the same as
anything with inflation
uh you know the only way to protect your
uh money like when i was a little kid
in elementary school i used to buy
suckers for 10 cents and take them to
school and sell them for 25 cents
to my to my classmates so i'd make 15
cents
every sucker and i'd sell like 20
suckers a day
and then one day i went to the store and
that sucker that was 10 cents my price
was now
25 cents so i had to buy them for 25
cents and sell them for 50 cents
i made more money but if i had bought in
boxes at 10 cents
then i would have been rich and that's
my philosophy with houses is
inflation hits you know and when
inflation hits
the only way to protect your money is to
have it invested in something that goes
up with inflation
instead of just sitting in the bank how
many of those houses are rented out
they're all i mean i bought my parents a
house like one of the first and
uh my house i live in and then and you
do all your own construction
yeah i build great yeah i've been to one
of your houses they're beautiful
yeah yeah dude i have a lot of really
it's incredible what you do with houses
man
it's [ __ ] badass i've obviously don't
do it alone i have a lot of good friends
that you know
our contractors and along the way i like
to be involved in it so i can learn
because
like what's the point if you can't learn
how to do it so i feel like you were
building a sauna
in one of your houses yeah i slept in
your house i was scared of the ghost in
your house
yeah wait wait what you did yeah when we
were in that one city
so anyway let me ask you this if you're
so [ __ ] entrepreneurial with your
suckers for 10 cents like the [ __ ] don't
you sell merch
well yeah good question steve
you have nine houses we have you're
watching
you got to find me somewhere like
where's waldo like where's danger and
i'll give you the one on my back
or i have a whole stack in my truck and
then you take the credit cards
that the people want to play with well
that's what i'm going to talk to you
guys about with thai box
yeah type box packaging so the merch
stuff
the merch stuff and all that comes with
the the whole idea of
in a sense fame and [ __ ] thing so
it goes against where you're at but no
it's not against it you want to sell
suckers for you at tight box
yeah [ __ ] yeah he's like does that
immediately
suck it with every purchase there you go
wow
honestly what i was doing and what i've
been doing and continue to do right now
is
i when i lived in l.a and i realized
that it like
basically whatever career i want to have
is based on what other people think
is cool whether they think i'm cool this
week or next week i'm not cool
and i like i don't want to live by that
i don't i need a base like a
i need a safe zone a place that i can
say okay if all that [ __ ] falls apart
i have a life and so that's why i moved
up back up to oregon and
did all this stuff and and i have that
now like i have a great
base that i've worked on for 15 years
like like i can say that if
the hollywood stuff and all this stuff
if it doesn't
happen anymore i don't care i have a
great life like i really don't need
to be hustling in the game of hollywood
like i don't i don't even like it's fun
and it's
like it brings me back to the old days
you know like being around
stuff fun like being in hollywood and
stuff but to be honest
without having that uh base and that
grounding
the being grounded in what's real
without having that i i didn't want to
be a part of
any of this fame and that's just the
reality
was there a moment that like made you
sort of distrust
fame or did you already come into it
with that sort of like this i already
knew because we're all going to die
like and all i cared about was living a
life where i was a good person and all
those around me
felt good about the name my my name and
who i was and whatever
your name sucks that's why we call you
change no no i'm just saying like
like you know and that's the truth yeah
all right so where can they buy the
merch
well we haven't figured that out yet but
i mean how did how did you lose your own
website to the russian hackers
man i don't know the russian hackers got
in and they just they were like we
were determined to get aaron.com so
sooner or later we'll be able to
facilitate merch on
that hopefully if the russian hackers
will let it go for
for less than a hundred thousand dollars
we're doing a venmo to give me my dot
com back if you want to venmo
that's called yeah
yeah all right dude well [ __ ] man um i i
do believe strongly that we're going to
get your merch operation up and running
yeah i do think that you're uh like a
i think you're a good person i think
you're a great guy
i think you've got a really healthy view
on the world
and your role in it you know i think
that we should take advantage of the
moment that we're about to have
for sure for sure and i love that that
you know we can do this together man
it's [ __ ] cool dude yeah yeah we love
you
i've had some great talks with you i
love you a lot well here's what i would
like to say in the end of all this in
this
awesome wild ride van is that um
you you asked how i maintained
being a somewhat normal real person and
it literally goes back to me being
a child uh growing up in a mortuary and
you asked
what are the benefits of that it was
very beneficial it opened up my
eyes if if let's say everybody at the
age of 18 has to experience death so
they can appreciate their life
i think that's a great thing but i was
experienced
at a very young age i didn't and it was
very impactful to my
whole existence and i just think
that that we we don't have a lot of time
on on earth
like we don't like 80 years is in a long
time 100 years
no there's never and you don't know when
it's going to end but i can tell you
that's in
my experience when i've died and i
survived something where
dmt was released in my brain and
i experienced death but survived and
the life flashed everything and then at
the end i was
able to let go surely dying
of my life on this planet because of
being at peace with my decisions and the
things i've done and who i am
and that is i think the most powerful
thing and the most important thing
that we all need to think about and
really
consider because it can come like that
how did you almost
your heart stopped no uh i went
skydiving
and oh dude i went skydiving for the
first time and only time and they
partnered me up with this dude
named stevo i'm not even kidding and and
he was a dread dreaded kid like in his
20s and i went skydiving
uh tandem and the parachute didn't open
correctly and so we went into this g4
spiral and then he cut the parachute
and then i i was falling and that was it
as far as i was concerned and i had no
control over
that dmt releasing in my brain it just
did it totally did and i was
that was it we were free falling to
death and he was screaming
too and i'm like and it popped
and you know that is one time and i've
had it another time
not as severe and i realized these
things it's just
really neat to like you know that's
crazy
yeah the thoughtful of the existence
there's a talk given by alan watts where
he was like
one of the best things you can do in
life is contemplate death for a long
time because it's a similar
thing where you it's like pouring manure
all over your brain
because then flowers start to spring
from it and i always kind of
really like that yeah that is good i
mean it's a western society thing man
people just don't want to [ __ ] think
about it they don't want to think it's
much better to think about it so that
you can
have lived your life deliberately
exactly you honor [ __ ]
exactly sure like you didn't just let
things happen to you you
you were good let's go party dude let's
go party
yeah dude i love you man you did really
well thanks for doing this man
thanks for having me yeah dude [ __ ]
right on and follow danger on instagram
yeah at danger aaron and buy his merch
at well we're gonna be going to uh
hopefullydangerairin.com
yeah give me my website back dogs i'm
back in the game
[Laughter]
that was fun how can you not love danger
aaron
he's just a sweet guy and he's my
bro you know like when i was talking
about hardware before
i loved the way that i got the hardware
removed from my ankle
and mounted in exactly the same way that
it was in my ankle on
a like the model of an ankle
i can't wait to do it again with the
plate and screws that i got in my
collarbone
of course i'm not going to say about how
i got it in my collarbone but i am gonna
say thank you guys for
watching listening whatever you do man i
just really appreciate it man can you
believe it [ __ ] episode 50.
i should have probably said that on the
intro but whatever
yeah dude